my name is Stephen chase and I'm an
assistant professor jointly appointed in
the department of biomedical engineering
and the Center for the neural basis of
cognition and I design brain computer
interfaces and I use these devices to
study motor learning and and motor
control we don't understand how your
brain controls your limb if we did we
could essentially make an arm that
looked as much like a limb as possible
we could just recreate that mapping and
you'd be off and running but we don't
understand that because limb control is
very very complicated so because we
can't make something exact you have to
learn how to use this artificial system
that isn't reacting much like what
natural motor control would do and the
idea is that if we can understand this
learning process better we can make
devices that will work when we plug them
in that we can get out to patients in
the real world and and and help them
bring a motor function I design brain
computer interfaces and I use them to
study motor control and motor learning
so a brain-computer interface takes
signals recorded signals from the brain
and the ones I use are directly from
neurons in primary motor cortex which is
the part of the brain that controls
movement and we take these recorded
signals from the brain and we use them
to directly control some device like a
cursor on computer screen or robotic arm
and the idea is that somebody who's lost
the ability to move if somebody was
paralyzed because of spinal cord injury
or brain stem stroke for whatever reason
but still has all of that motor control
ability locked into their head we can
take these devices we can tap out the
intention to move and then we can move a
device for them so I've created this in
some senses arbitrary mapping between
neural activity and cursor movement and
the brain is very good at figuring out
from the from the small movements that
the cursor makes how to refine that
process and how to make the cursor do
what you want it to do and that's the
process I study we're trying to
understand that learning process we're
trying to understand how to design a
brain-computer interface that is more
learnable that is that you can learn
more quickly that you can learn
use more naturally that's that's the
work I do Carnegie Mellon really
encourages collaboration and that the
kinds of things I do Unite's techniques
from statistics machine learning
neurobiology engineering and and so no
one person could really be an expert in
all of those various fields but we work
together so I work with people in
statistics I work with people in machine
learning and together we approach these
questions about the brain from all these
different perspectives and and Carnegie
Mellon really encourages that